Add fabulous texture to
your knitting with bobbles.
If you can put needles
in hold, you can do this.
The idea behind bobbles is
partial knitting or bridging.
Keep only the bobble stitches in work.
Knit a few rows, hang the bobble.
Rinse and repeat.
We found some tricks for making
these neat without any extra fuss.
The goal is to knit only one garment
row while we're  adding our bobbles.
With the carriage on the
right, put needles into hold,
set the carriage to hold.
It will stay in, hold
through the whole process.
Knit to the left, across
the needles in work.
Wrap the first needle.
Keeping the three bobble
needles in working position,
put the remaining needles in hold.
As you can see only
three needles are work.
Knit five rows or an odd number of rows
ending with the carriage on the right.
Wrap that needle to the right.
Pick up the stitches from the
first row of the bobble and
hang them on the bobble needles.
Put the next set of needles into
working position and knit to the
left across all of those needles.
This completes your first bobble.
Closes up those stitches and you're
set up for your next sequence.
Put all but the next three
bobble needles into hold.
These three will be the second bobble.
Wrap the needle on the left, knit
five rows ending on the right.
Wrap the right needle.
Pick up the three stitches and hang
that bobble from the first row.
Put the next set of needles
into working position.
Knit across.
You've completed the second bobble
and you're in position to create
the next and the next and the next.
Now here are the tricks.
You'll position the carriage
correctly by knitting an odd
number of rows for the bobble.
In my case, five.
Wrapping on each side, prevents holes.
Picking up the first row of stitches
gives that bobble the desired dimension.
As you can see in this example, only
one row was knit, keeping the row
count, correct for the garment piece.